okay Luke I'll try not to go too hard on
you Luke Cage is back season two so I am
at the time of this recording six
episodes in so generally with these
things being 13 episodes Long's I like
to break em I add roughly the halfway
point and give my assessment up to this
point and so that when I do a review
after having seen the back end I can
focus on how it wraps up so quick recap
on my feelings about the first season of
this because I reviewed that back when I
had a fraction of the subscribers that I
have right now the first season of Luke
Cage lost me halfway through basically
at the point of which spoilers for the
first season suppose for the first six
episodes of this to eventually when I
get there but definitely for the first
season right now when they killed
cottonmouth at the halfway mark now the
way in which he was killed was epic and
awesome and probably the best thing in
the entire show
and then they brought in a secondary
villain named Diamondback and who was
nowhere near as compelling they had
spent all this time building up
cottonmouth and then killed him they
spend almost no time Britain actually
building up Diamondback they just had
him mentioned
occasionally it was like oh he's a guy
who exists then he shows up and they try
to have all this weird pathos and
history between him and Luke agent none
of it rang true and the final fight was
a complete wet squib of a thing so I
really felt that the first season of
Luke Cage fell apart in the second half
so how is the first half of season two
so far it's a bit slow it's actually
it's reminding me of the Punisher which
folks may recall I gave up on after five
episodes I'm not giving up on Luke Cage
but if I didn't already like most of
these characters it would be in danger
of me give
up on it so that's that's not good the
problem is they seem to have really
adopted from the comic books the
decompressed storytelling thing they
take three episodes to accomplish what
most TV shows would do in one episode I
don't think they do it for any reason
other than I it feels like the
approaches they sat down go here's the
story for the season how do we search
this out - 13 episodes and I am going
well crap this is probably an 8 episodes
story and then they just stretch all
over the place now so far none of the
stretching has involved characters just
be killed outright for new people to be
crowbar dating and progressing the story
that way I did get nervous in episode 6
when there was a showdown between a
couple of characters that made me
thought oh god are they about to do the
same thing that they did last season
they didn't so props to that but before
I get into anything else because I have
a feeling I'll probably be nitpicking a
bit Mike Colter and this part is great
he's always been great he was great when
he showed up in Jessica Jones he was
great in the defenders he's great in the
first season of this he is a really good
Luke Cage he's awesome
Mariah Dillard as the character is a
character who I like but I feel like her
story is one of those ones that they are
really dragging out her whole arc over
more and they're there so they've got
slow motion for her whole storyline and
so it shades ties into that and shades
is character I really like that said I'm
gonna mention this now in case you
forget it later there is a scene between
him and a new character named I believe
it's Comanche then they have this
episode this quiet this quiet scene
between just the two of them in Episode
six that I love I I can't explain what
it is like getting the spoiler it's not
that it's like a major plot point but I
mean it's six episodes in I love it so
much if you've seen it I'm hoping you
know that the the one
the scene I'm talking about and I don't
know how it'll get played in later
episodes I'm hoping not badly because
for the scene itself man I love it it's
great and shades was the character who I
really liked in the first season cuz I
like the whole sort of angle he seemed
to have going you know jumping from
cottonmouth Diamondback Moriah and just
sort of leaping on where he thinks
there's potential III question cuz they
seem to be playing a very genuine
affection between him and Mariah and I
don't feel like that's been properly
justified on his end so I'm not entirely
sure I'm following why he is as seems to
be developing that level of feeling
towards her other than you know they're
a man and a woman who share a whole lot
of scenes in a TV show apparently that's
the law but I'm oh so I'm a little
nervous about that but overall I still
like him as a character misty Zach
Misty's awesome misty was always awesome
Claire is good for as long as she sticks
around she's not around as much as I
would have hoped but she and Mike Colter
have really good chemistry rosario
Dawson is great in this part
she's been I mean she's been great since
daredevil so Rosie Rios is one of those
actors who's good in everything even if
it's a bad thing that she's in she's
still good she was she was even good in
hired fists that's how good she is as
far as other characters go you know you
got a whole bunch of supporting
characters come back I feel like other
characters from other Marvel Netflix
shows that were better integrated and
their cameos felt less forced so the
scene in which misty is there's a couple
of scenes that misty has with Colleen
that's another highlight actually their
stuff together is really good and it
feels natural feels organic how they
come to have those scenes together and
they work great off each other
foggy shows up and his partner again
feels very organic feels very true to
the character and feels very on
forced so I am liking that it the this
show more than any other seems to have
really settled into a sense of
casualness with the connections to the
other Netflix shows and I think that's a
good thing so I'm down with all that the
villain the new villain Bushmaster he
made a heck of a first impression he
made a solid debut he then did something
pretty neat following that and then he's
just kind of moving really slowly like
for a guy who seemed to to come into the
story swing in he seems to now just have
back in the corner and like he's biding
his time and I don't know why well I
mean you know six episode things picked
up a little bit I'm not entirely sure
how we got from him you know just
hitting the ground running to him sort
of just scheming they they see it they
seem to be at odds there seems to be two
different things going on there and
again it feels like the sort of thing
for Sandow by the fact that they have to
stretch this out into 13 episodes I'm
not sure there's I've got too much else
to say I mean for having having now
watched of almost 6 hours of television
I've surprisingly little to say because
a lot less has happened that I would
have expected or would have hoped would
have happened in that amount of time on
a TV show so I mean that said the pacing
is at least steadily moving forward
because like in and season 1 after they
killed cottonmouth it wasn't just that
like things slowed down it was like
things came to a grinding halt and then
had to restart nothing like that has
happened so even though the pacing is
not what I would like it to be it is all
moving forward at the very least nothing
is felt like a major back step although
with Luke maybe it's been too long since
I've seen season 1 I don't remember him
having anger issues to the degree that
I'm seeing here and they seem to be
leaning on that a fair bit to move some
of the plot points forward and I'm not
entirely sure how I feel about that
because it feels
unjustified but you know that there are
some there are some interesting things
that play when characters actually talk
about the roots of their power or their
influence or why they act the way they
act and I think there's some there's
some decent commentary going on there I
found it especially interesting with
Mariah sort of talking about not being
ashamed to use the illicit Lee gained
funds that that her family came by for
their initial power and you know the
idea that and nobody says this part
outright but the fact that look if
you're if you're black and wealthy you
eat that either happened very recently
or something is shady is probably in
your history and your family's past
because black people were barred from
earning fortunes legitimately for a long
time so you know the fact that mariah
comes from a family that tree even two
whole generations back were
significantly powerful yeah that's kind
of how they were going to get there and
again nobody says that outright but it
is an undercurrent and it's one that
feels very appropriate to the to the
story and every and to the characters
and everything else that's going on I'm
not sure how much of themes of those
sorts of things I'll dive into just
because I feel like I don't really have
as firm a graph and certainly not a
personal point of reference that other
people might but like that was one that
I feel like I think I see what the shows
do doing there and I like it so so that
one I wanted to bring up specifically I
think that's about it though I mean it's
pretty good so far it's lacking like a
real oomph to it there hasn't been and
the Netflix shows are still shooting
some of these scenes way too dark but
there's been a couple of decent action
scenes but I mean Luke
as badass as he is and he's perfectly
capable of being badass in fight scenes
his fight scenes aren't especially
dynamic he gets punched and shot at and
has glass broken over him he's unfazed
and then he beats everybody up or or
every now and then he gets his butt
kicked just to show you all stuff just
got real now so you know he doesn't have
the most dynamic fight scenes in the
world and maybe that's part of the
reason we don't we haven't had something
like sort of do you see the siege on
Fort Knox or whatever was they called it
back I think of episode 3 of the first
season but but lacking that and sort of
lacking the pacing that I would prefer
i-i-i had hoped things would have picked
up more than they have by this point in
the story that's that I'm not
disappointed yet wild the number of
things that I actively like oh god the
music holy crap I don't even know if I
talked about the music in the first
season the music was great the first
season it's even better this season like
I'll probably actually buy this
soundtrack and cut and like a fair
amount of the music is music that isn't
normally what's on my radar but this is
good stuff okay can't believe I almost
forgot to mention that but yeah I think
that that'll about do it it's it's solid
so far there's nothing actively ticking
me off about it like had already
happened with season two of Jessica
Jones by this point so you know there
are things that I'm nervous about in
terms of whether or not the show will
sort of you know get them you have them
pay off and get them moving better but
as of right now it's solid I want to see
how it sticks the landing because
backends of seasons have been the weak
parts of these Netflix shows for the
most part so we'll see what happens
first six episodes of Luke Cage I think
I managed to do that pretty spoiler free
I think I'll even put that in the title
have you seen them what did you think
about them whatever your thoughts are
drop something down to comments let's
talk about it feel free to talk spoilers
for these six episodes not for any of
the ones later
if you could but there's all the stuff
that you can do support me on patreon
follow me on Twitter listen to my
podcast buy t-shirts send me stuff to my
PO Box links for all this stuff is down
in the description so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]